but we do begin with a deadly winter
storm that slammed a huge swath of the
country from the Midwest to the Mid
Atlantic record snowfall brought some
places to a standstill
the massive storm is now blamed for at
least nine deaths over the weekend
nearly 120,000 people across four states
are without power governors in North
Carolina and Virginia declared states of
emergency Kris Van Cleave is on the road
in Ashburn Virginia that is just outside
Washington Chris good morning
good morning the Ashburn area got up to
11 inches of snow and if you're on a
side road like we are it is icy it is
still snow-covered which is making
driving treacherous some 25 thousand
people are waking up in Virginia without
power it is bitterly cold outside the
federal government is shut down and a
lot of the schools are to the massive
winter storm stretched more than 1400
miles and spread havoc across roadways
throughout the Midwest in parts of
Missouri more than 20 inches fell I got
in as far as I could off the road and
that was it drivers caught in the snow
and ice were stranded for hours with
Missouri police responding to more than
900 crashes over the weekend trucks out
were ready to go but the intensity we
couldn't keep up at least four people
died on Missouri roads including Dee Ann
and Olivia Phillips Deanne lost control
of her car on a snow-covered Road and
drifted into the path of an oncoming
vehicle in Wilson Kansas tow truck
drivers were busy pulling cars off the
side of Interstate 70 and in Indiana I
65 looked like a semi parking lot after
a crash shut down part of the freeway
for hours the storm caused travel chaos
at airports across the nation - on
Friday this plane slid off the runway in
Columbia Missouri as it was taxiing to
the gate no one was hurt more than 800
flights were cancelled over the weekend
thousands more delayed due to whiteout
conditions the effects of the storm
could be felt as far south as North
Carolina where ice brought down trees
and power lines in the nation's capital
the storm dropped 10 inches of snow
becoming the worst winter storm here
since 2016 and you can see the
conditions here on the side roads the
real concern now that the snow is
stopped
we'll be ice it remains bitterly cold
here in Virginia so ice is going to
continue to be a problem as we said the
federal government is shut down and of
course there's the potential for another
winter storm coming our way here by next
weekend John all right Chris everybody
be careful out there